okay it is time to watch the Grand Theft
Auto 6 trailer one is what they've
called it on the channel Grand Theft
Auto 6 trailer one they really just went
right in there with it this did get
leaked I did not watch any of the leaks
frankly I think the leaks suck we're
very anti-leak uh they had to release it
a little bit early um it's a huge bummer
I don't know why anybody would try to
leak something literally a day in
advance just to take it away from a
publisher but here we are so what am I
expecting from this trailer I made a
video maybe two we ago three weeks ago
that was effectively me saying let
Rockstar cook I think they are one of
the goats they are one of the greatest
game studios of all time one of if not
the best that we have um and it is
always worth waiting for them that is my
stance I will wait for them as long as
they need me to wait for them I will be
here um I think that they are just in A
League of Their Own and a lot of that
which I'll link to that video in case
you want to watch it is because they get
their own funding which is like such a
unique position in the games industry
like very very very unique I'm expecting
to see some impressive new AI in terms
of the way NPCs function in the open
world I think that that's something that
Rockstar specifically really iterates on
very well um which for the record we're
not anti- AI in the games industry we're
just anti- certain kinds of AI but not
all of it we use AI all the time AI can
be good in a lot of cases I think this
is set in uh Miami um seems like a vice
a new Vice City obviously not actual
Florida but that's what I'm expecting
probably a much larger map than we had
in VI city which makes me also expect
good music I feel like that's like such
a core part of Vice City very very very
important updated animation I would like
to see some updated combat that is the
only thing that I think that I don't
like 10 out of 10 love from a rockstar
game whatever let's do it let's go okay
tell me if the audio is
[Music]
okay
luia do you know why you're here bad
luck I
guess
dude I'm so
excited have go SP oh my God hav even
done anything and I'm like
oh okay I'm not going to do this it's
going to annoy people I'll play through
the whole thing but holy the
nightclub that's probably a cut scene
but video games are so bad at nightclubs
cyber Punk is like the best most are AB
absolutely terrible let me let's okay
let's watch through the whole trailer
first we're only 32 seconds in and then
come back
[Music]
around the hair
physics the twerk
[Applause]
physics that's
[Music]
interesting
is well look who's
back the only way we're going to get
through
this is by sticking together being a
team I still have Goosebumps
trust
trust is that
Troy
okay so um clearly just a bunch of shots
of GTA adjacent things happening in in
this um not a huge indication of story
which is totally fine it's literally a
first trailer I expect we'll get more at
the game awards I don't actually
know um but obviously a huge focus on
vehicle Variety in every single shot
like even this there is such a specific
focus on vehicle variety if you actually
go to a beach you never really see this
much activity so they're being like yeah
we got sharks we got PODS of dolphins oh
we got speedboats this is like a little
yacht down the bottom all obviously very
GTA online adjacent
stuff um very specific about the amount
of vehicles and the amount of wildlife
which seems like a massive step up from
previous
games a lot of wildlife I feel like this
old
so a pretty massive variety of NPC types
here like I would think that these are
all different body
types they got some they got some good
ass work done here I'm trying to see if
any of these two NPCs even look like
they're wearing the same thing those
aren't the same I was going to say two
blue pairs of pants no
oh that's kind of cut off but he's got a
camera and he's taking a photo of
bending over lovely The Vibes are very
Miami that's so funny um I'm not seeing
a single repeated NPC maybe this that is
probably the same bikini all the way up
here as right here um but that's
something that I think Rockstar is like
excellent at that I know that they
patented new tech 4 or at least that was
a leak I'm actually I can't say I know I
don't know if that was confirmed that uh
you know it was I think GTA 4 wasn't
even GTA 5 where it's like at the time
revolutionary that if it rain in the
city people would pull out an umbrella
or they would like put whatever they
were holding over their head sometimes
like it was a bag or it was a newspaper
and I believe what they're trying to do
which again is AI sometimes we like AI
in video games again every game has AI
not anti- aai in video games only
certain kinds where they're trying to
like combine a mood with a reaction so
you will have maybe the same response to
rain uh but that you would have someone
swear while doing it or someone be pled
while doing it you know just an
expansion on that that previous Tech um
also noticing the amount of Sky Vehicles
this looks like a little drone back here
let me that there some sort of drone
probably all things you're going to be
able to fly not sure about the quantis
ass looking Boe up there sea helicopter
lot of options lot of options the city
looks pretty big but it's kind of hard
to say super impressed by the hair
physics hair is really really
hard again a lot of vehicles and Miami
is like it's a really interesting map
[Music]
too it looks so
populated so
populated
damn oh that looks beautiful this hair
got
me that's crazy also this would indicate
maybe you could live up here a lot of
focus on partying suits the vibe of
Miami it does look mad dense in the
background I mean again they've always
got multiple Vehicles oh Rockstar dude
they're just so good like I get
so excited about a rockstar game and I
again I made a video about it we don't
need to do this
again because I already done it they're
just so uniquely positioned to spend the
most money anyone has ever spent on a
video game ever in a way that nobody
else is like not even close because they
make so much money it's oh it just
doesn't exist
there's no other game Studio that would
really ever be allowed to spend as much
money as Rockstar consistently spends
they always break their own records are
the most expensive game ever made and
it's only because of the way that
they've done GTA online at this point
it's nuts not even valve they don't make
games Star Citizen isn't out doesn't
count just
G so this is the next thing that I
wanted to talk about this trailer has a
huge focus on whatever this is otherwise
you wouldn't have so many cuts of this
like fake social media and I wonder if
that is going to be something to do with
them changing Rockstar Social Club I
think they recently made some changes to
it I think I saw that in news headlines
I'm wondering if there's going to be
some sort of in-game version you know
how they've like recently been using
phones like in GTA 5 you actually pull
up your phone be able to do things I
wonder if there's going to be a focus on
like an in-game social
media and maybe that is the bridge to
online services I could be I could see
myself getting a little concerned about
that I want the the single player
experience to be a single player
experience please let it be a single
player experience please please that's I
really really really want that but maybe
there's a version I mean there's such a
focus on like photography selfies all
that maybe there is a version of of
sharing through the social club on a I
don't know I would really like to find
out more information about that because
it concerns me a little bit
[Applause]
[Music]
why that I mean it's very
unique thrillbilly Mud
Club well look who's
back the only way we're going to get
through this and she's our protagonist I
assume is by sticking together but
that's probably going to
be something gang related
as is very common for Rockstar
trust
[Music]
[Applause]
trust I have
questions which is always how I want it
to be to be honest never want all my
questions answered it looks real good it
looks real good it just makes me so
excited for another Rockstar game that's
the my biggest takeaway
so yeah clearly we need more info I am
so fine with
waiting I don't need any of it right now
it's
okay uh coming out in 2025
apparently also cool with that um like I
said I'll wait as long as Rockstar needs
I know people like it'll be delayed all
the games are always delayed fine delay
whatever you delay things as long as you
need to delay them I have no problem
with you doing that
whatsoever go for it